now despite mounting evidence of a real
migrant surge and a real crisis
at the border strained resources all the
chaos were witnessing
the biden administration still
steadfastly is refusing to acknowledge
what is in fact reality a full-blown
crisis
as new documents obtained by axios show
how the biden administration's resources
at the border are already stretched to
capacity
that the hhs shelter system is on track
to hit a 100 percent capacity
this month alone and this is just the
beginning
now we have our own investigative
reporter sarah carter she's live again
at the border on the ground in texas
with the latest
even watching the apprehension of the
illegal immigrants earlier today sarah
yes sean i've been here all day i'm in
the rio grande valley sector in mcallen
texas
actually just several miles from the
mexico border
and we ran into immigrants earlier today
actually the majority of them were young
children here in this sector as they are
flooding
into the country sean i can tell you
this there's roughly
between 700 to a thousand uh
undocumented migrants some of them
unaccompanied minors
pouring into texas daily the border
patrol agents in this sector
are are overwhelmed with the amount of
people that are coming in and remember
there's a crisis as well
on the southern border with the drug
cartels battling it out as well as human
traffickers
i think the hardest part today sean was
running into the young children
there were children as young as four
years old in this group
many of them were traveling by
themselves without any adults
some of them met up with adults on the
on the journey to the united states
all of the children that i ran into were
from honduras
they had been traveling for
approximately three months
many of them had spent time on top of
the trains they talked about la bestia
it's a train that runs through mexico
that the kids jump on top of
and try to make their way to the u.s
mexico border
they told me horror stories about
children that had fallen off the train
children that disappeared while they
were on the road with them that this is
a real humanitarian crisis
but i thought what was more interesting
was that the children
actually knew president biden i asked
them
do you know who the president of the
united states is they said
yes of course it's president biden and
they misinterpreted his stop on
deportations
uh for 100 days as being an invitation
to arrive to the united states they said
that the
human traffickers the cartels the people
that were moving them into the united
states
basically said it was about a hundred
days to get here
to freedom so that they once they got
here they would have amnesty
these kids were willingly turning
themselves into border patrol
i can't tell you how heartbreaking it is
though when you know that none of these
the children at least that i spoke to
had seen doctors
many of them said that their parents
were still back in honduras
that they were trying to find family
here in the united states and that their
parents sent them ahead of them
some of these children we don't even
know if they were actually traveling
with their actual parents we actually
believe that they may be
traveling with strangers that their
parents were paid
to bring them on this journey i spoke
with chris cabrera
he is the national border patrol council
vice president president for the union
and here's what he had to say as a bp
agent what goes through your mind when
you see this when you see
this influx of young people and know
that they have traveled like probably
one of the most dangerous routes
to get to the united states it's
heartbreaking to see that you know i
mean
you think about these kids what they go
through on the journey
how many of these kids don't make it how
many how many how many don't make it
the full journey because there's nobody
there watching out for them what's in
their best interest
what kind of surge are you expecting
this year yeah we're expecting thousands
a day
right now we're between 700 and a
thousand daily
and we're seeing that number increase
for the most part daily i mean it ebbs
and flows
but it's steadily increasing and the
unique part is
years ago this was just something that
we dealt with in the rio grande
not the rest of the united states and
now we're seeing it from the rio grande
valley sector all the way to san diego
it's happening all over the border
they're coming in large groups in laredo
in in big bend in el paso and arizona
huge groups are coming in
because they know that they're going to
be let go and once they get here no
matter
what they hear our politicians say if
our politicians say don't come right now
well we'll send you back it's as long as
one person gets through
they call back home and said this is
what we did we got through and more are
going to follow what i would tell
president biden or anybody else in
up in dc that has any type of authority
is
this needs to stop being a partisan
issue i'm not saying that it's partisan
issue on him i'm just saying
in general you know with the republicans
the democrats
if you want to solve this problem you
have to leave your partisan hat at the
door they have a
fence around the capitol now i mean so
if it's if it's good for these folks it
should be good for
the rest of america it should be for our
country
yeah sean i mean the crisis couldn't be
any worse they say they're expecting
these numbers to increase by the
thousands
uh come springtime there's a lot of
concern here about where they're going
to house these children
and more and more undocumented children
are coming across the border we're also
seeing a lot of family units
and there's a big concern here as well
with the spread of covid
and the fact that the majority of people
coming through are not being tested
and remember the dhs secretary sarah
said we want you to come but just don't
come right now
so to be clear these these families
with children and it's tragic it's
tragic this is a perilous journey a
one where people are dying making this
journey
uh they feel there's an open invitation
by the president of the united states to
come
a and b they still won't let you get
inside the cargo ship containers
uh with the little window with bars on
it you have no access to that you have
tried correct
absolutely we've tried correct and we
have not heard a response back from the
dhs
i can tell you this that dhs secretary
mallorcas
a lot of people are very concerned uh
about the message that he's putting
across about the message that there
isn't a crisis
i can tell you that the border patrol
agents here in the rio grande valley
sector
are doing a tremendous job they're doing
everything they can to stop this flow
and by the way
they're doing everything they can to
comfort these children and at the same
time fend off the drug cartels
there's no doubt that these are real
heroes on on the u.s mexico border here
okay sarah thank you